well we've demonstrated on a number of
occasions over the period of devolution
that you can successfully
run a government in the senate on 30
seats
uh but i will be prepared to work with
other parties in the senate of course
no party has a monopoly of good ideas
and where there are policies on which
there is common ground
then i will always be keen to work with
others
when that is to the advantage of wales
whatever party it is so you'd be happy
to work on policies with the
conservatives blood country
any other party well
the conservative party even in this
election had a policy of a clean
air act for wales we are also committed
to such a piece of legislation so
where there is some common ground and i
think
you know the senate works well when we
are able to work across party lines
and to deliver outcomes that make a
difference in the lives of welsh people
now the story of labrum wales is very
different
to what's happened in the rest of
england we've seen
labour hemorrhaging seats across england
and the council elections
losing the hartlepool by-election in
wales you've managed to hang on to some
of those critical red wall seats wrexham
for example
delon that many thought would fall to
the conservatives why do you think that
is
well i think the big advantage we have
over some of our colleagues in england
is that we have been in government here
in wales we're able to
demonstrate to welsh people but when we
say in our manifesto that we will
achieve something on their behalf that
we have a record that demonstrates
that we have done so successfully when
you're in opposition
you you put forward ideas you show what
you'd like to do
but you're not actually in a position of
being able to put those things
into practice in the way that you are if
you are in government
and that's been to our advantage in this
election
at the same time though some of the
things that people uh in
team kirstama have been blaming the
result on whether it's you know
jeremy corbyn uh whether it's brexit
whether it's a vaccine bound to mean
you know you are also in this situation
it doesn't seem to have tainted you
in the same way you've got any tips for
kirst dharma
well uh i know that sequistama will want
to have a review of
these elections across the united
kingdom we'll be very
keen to contribute to that and if there
are any things that
we've been able to do in wales that
would be of interest to others of course
we'll be there
to do so i think the fact that
wales has the lowest rate of coronavirus
anywhere in the united kingdom the
fastest rate of vaccination
all of that has been noticed by people
in wales
when i've been on the doorstep people
have been very keen to say
that they are glad they've lived in
wales over the last 15 months
they feel that they've been kept safe
during the pandemic
and then of course people want to talk
about the future as well
and being in government means that
you've got a platform
from which you can hold those
conversations
do you think that kia stammer needs to
take a few more risks come up with a few
more policies
well i think labour's had a whole
tranche of very popular
policies